joining me today as a sociologist a
physician a professor at Yale University
and author of the new book blueprint the
evolutionary origins of a good society
Nick Christakis welcome to the Rubin
report thank you for having me dude I am
happy to have you here sir but I'm
depressed that I have to start the show
the way I sword I have to start the show
yeah inspect you know how I have to
start the show yeah so you want to set
it up for me well I mean we do just have
to get this out I know I know I mean I
knew when the book was published I mean
I've been working in the book for nine
years and I knew when it was published
that I would have to revisit those
events from 2015 which you know we're
just a challenging period of my life
thankfully in the past I'm really glad
to have it behind me yeah but I
recognized that so you tell whatever
part of it you want to tell okay so you
are and were a professor at Yale yes
this is this isn't I think the fall of
2015
yes fall of 2015 and your wife Erica
who's also a professor childhood
development
she was an instructor but yes she
basically wrote a piece that said it was
a defense of free speech and it was sort
of worked around the Halloween costume
idea that you know you should wear what
you want but you can try to be
respectful of people but you know we
shouldn't have some sort of top-down
version where people you know
administrators or professors or telling
students what to wear you offered her a
bit of a defense on that and now all
throw to the clip is that fair fair okay
let's throw to the clip don't need to
bend down I'm not bending what's your
name I do not respect you hear that I'm
looking at the smirk on your face like
I'm disgusted okay I'm sick and I'm sick
watching them argue with you after we've
been standing outside literally for at
least five to six hours between you and
Holloway between last night to now we've
been arguing with people who are not
willing to be listened to for a long
time and all I see from you is arrogance
and ego
I am sick looking at you I am disgusted
watching elects argue with you you were
not listening you were disgusting I
don't think you understand that and if
before I wasn't I before I was not angry
per se I was disappointed maybe I
thought maybe there was room for it
before an apology you've clearly told us
that you do not plan to offer an apology
for your words you left the meeting last
night to go home and then tweet do not
interrupt me to tweets from your Twitter
and then the filaments Twitter you
showed no remorse you tried to let your
wife believe that conversation without
having answered for herself that is
disgusting
that is sick and now I wasn't angry
before and was not angry before but now
I am actually angry sir I really do not
interrupt me I was not angry and now I
want your job to be taken from you I
don't want you to have this job I am
disgusted knowing that you work at Yale
University where I will get my degree
where I will look back and think I have
to argue with you don't do it don't do
it sir do not do it this is not the day
you do not want to play this game with
me do something you know what whose game
with me okay understand that look at me
in my face first of all and understand
that you are such a disappointment to
this University to your students to
yourself the things that you cling to
agree with you were you want free dialog
you want free speech this is how it
works someone speaks you listen you
don't cut them off you do not do these
these condescending gestures you do not
smirk you look them in the face and you
wait you wait until it is your turn okay
so before we even dive into that the
second we played the clip you let out a
big exhale it was interested in this
anymore
yeah it's depressing to look back both
are true it's you know it's I was in the
courtyard for two hours and 15 minutes
from 4:00 to 6:00 15 about an hour of
footage has been released of from five
or six different vantage points you
showed one clip that's typically not the
clip that's shown so many people put
stuff online you can reap you can piece
together the whole hour between 5 & 6
for the first hour that I was out in the
courtyard I listened quietly to the
students you know there's a lot of stuff
that that young woman said that's just
factually wrong she's alluding to an
event that occurred the night before at
the Africa afro-american cultural house
at Yale where there was a huge event
with hundreds of students it had been
announced at the beginning that we would
have to leave that event at the
conclusion it was I can't remember the
precise timing but I think it was
scheduled from 6:00 to 8:00 my wife had
to teach a class from 7:00 to 9:00 so
she'd in the evening so she told her
students she'd be late and we'd stay
from 6:00 to 8:00 she did in fact speak
to the crowd she had to leave to teach
and I we had a student in the hospital
actually that evening that I was
responsible for and that also was known
so so when she said that we tried to
leave that's not that's false you know I
think that many of the students were
swept up in a kind of a mob fervor I
think they behaved badly they should
have known better I think they were
trying to assert power if I had a tool
when I was that age that could get
grown-ups into trouble right you know
probably I would just kept doing it
non-stop and they had found a tool yes
yes yes and and so but so I think what
distressed me is I think at some point
in the background of that footage that
one of the administrators actually the
author what happened is is a man by the
name of Birdwell Howard had moved from
North Western University to Yale and had
assumed a new position there and he had
written an email he had written an a
memo while at Northwestern admonishing
students not to wear offensive costumes
and I should say for the record that
many of the students that many of the
costumes that he or anyone else would
find offensive I too would find
offensive I wouldn't like these costumes
I'm well aware of the long history of
racism in our society I'm well aware of
the ways in which there's trafficking
and certain cultural tropes that put
down other groups I reject I am of I
have a very Pro immigrant policy I
belief system i i i think that anyone
can be an american i love the idea that
we have open borders you know i mean i
have a set of beliefs that are around
openness and welcoming you're a lefty
yeah i am quite a let I am a lefty I'm
left of center play I mean I have some
conservative ideas some libertarian I I
think of myself as a classical liberal
and I think of myself as very pragmatic
in policymaking so I like I like markets
to address most allocation of goods but
I also very concerned about market
failures and then I want government
intervention anyway so so so that anyway
that man who was a then had moved to
Yale and then he took out of mothballs
this email that he had sent at
Northwestern five or ten years earlier
got a bunch of Yale administrators to
sign it and then send it off and in it
he had links to approved and non
approved costumes the very costumes
which were deemed to be offensive in his
email there were links to lots of those
ostensibly offensive costumes and the
students there had been a lot of
conversation at the time the New York
Times had a big piece like the previous
month about the growing use of Halloween
costume advice at American colleges so
it was in the zeitgeist this was the
third his email was the third email that
had been sent out telling students
giving them advice so in my wife's class
many of the students in the class and
other students in the college where we
the sub part of Yale that we were
responsible for had told her that they
felt this was very infantilizing and
they didn't really need advice on what
to wear and so my wife from a
developmental perspective wrote a
response to this email which itself had
been was signed by 13 administrators it
it didn't it was framed as guidance but
it sort of had the color of law and so
she wrote a response saying and her
intellectual point was not where
whatever you want right her intellectual
point was do use students at Yale in
your 20s early to knit late teens early
20s really need older adults to tell you
what to wear provide you guidance you
should think about that and decide
whether you really and apparently many
students didn't want such guidance and
so then I was then thereafter there all
hell broke loose and I was in a
courtyard and did the best I could yeah
what do you make of the reason we chose
that cliff
because there is the other more famous
clip of the girl Lily berating you in
there were many many that were done I
heard that that was the one that I think
we note here and that I think that's the
most violent but I thought that one was
interesting because the angle was a
little different and you could see some
of the other kids and and the you know
the tears or the look of horror or all
of these things when you actually didn't
do anything yes well that's another
whole topic I think that I mean many
people have analyzed those events and
honestly I don't I don't know if I have
anything to add to those analyses I
think that the the thing that was very
interesting to me so so one of the ideas
that I've been thinking about for a long
time is this tension between our
individuality and our group business and
we have evolved - first of all it's a
very interesting idea we've evolved to
be individuals so we humans have unique
identities so we have unique faces so
you can look at a sea of people and can
tell who's who and not only do we have
the ability to signal our uniqueness you
we use our faces for that but we have
the cognitive apparatus to detect that
uniqueness so you you can have a lot of
brain power you haven't done you
allocate to tell who's ooh so this
ability to be individuals is crucial for
our ability to function in groups it's
very paradoxical because you need that
capacity to tell who is my offspring
who's my friend who do i reciprocate
kindness to who do i cooperate with
who's my enemy all of these things so
all of these capacities of individuality
are crucial to our collective expression
our ability to live together but equally
we we have this desire to surrender
ourselves to the group to do something
called 2d individuate to form a part of
a collectivity to suppress our
individual desires which also allows us
to work together but the irony is when
you get too much of that you get mobs
you get panics you get you know all
kinds of collective phenomena that are
destructive rather than constructive so
when I was in the the crowd when I was
in that mob I I knew what was happening
I could tell so one of the things I
started doing was is I started asking
people what's your name mm-hmm
and I was trying to connect to them
person-to-person saying you know hi I'm
Nicolas who are you so you're a person
and I'm a person you're not a part of
this a mob you are a human being and I'm
a human being and in fact the one thing
that happened that that isn't is an
intellectual idea that's part of this
book that I've been working on for 10
years but that's also I made in the heat
of the moment is in the moment I said to
the students I said that I believe in
our common humanity I believe that even
though this person and this person is
superficially different than me
nevertheless we can talk to each other
we all have life experiences we're human
beings and end it and then if you if you
don't believe that if you don't believe
we have a common humanity which I see as
a wonderful thing yeah optimist if you
don't believe in our common humanity why
are you even trying to talk to me and
the students jeered yeah they jeered
it's on film they jeered and I honestly
I think that's one of the most
depressing things that's happened that
I've ever seen actually said the Yale
students in the 21st century would jeer
at what I regard to be a fundamental
humane wonderful claim about human
beings is that we have a common humanity
so all right so I know you don't want to
spend the whole time I don't but I do
but I think a lot of this does segue to
your book reasons that you just laid out
so I was trying to do that here's a
tidbit CPI watch what I'm gonna get but
that look that you're talking about when
you say that like we have been able to
share yeah I'm in humanity I've been
there too I mean I face these mobs and
what I find is there there's an actual
look they haven't yes we're the
individual that you just spoke about is
gone yes yes did you think there was
anything so I guess there's really in
that case for the people that are
watching this that think that one day
they're gonna go against the mob is
there any other advice you would have
for them on how to how to do it because
I know I always work I mean saying I've
done that where I've said I'm standing
right in for and listening to yes my
name is Dave yes
and it done I think that
I I don't know III I don't know you know
there's that there's that scene in Lord
of the Rings where Aragorn rushes the
gates you know and of Mordor and I of
course love those movies and you know I
don't know if I would have I don't think
I don't know if I would be capable of
such bravery but intellectually I
definitely a.m. that is to say I'm not
easily cloud and I spent my life
training myself to think as clearly as I
can to look at evidence to collect
evidence I'm an obscene 'test I'm an
empiricist so so in the in the case of a
mob I don't think I would yield to a mob
intellectually now physically you know
if they're if they're throwing bricks at
you is a different thing right but I
think you often that threat is always
there even if they're not holding a
weapon yeah it's right under it's a
dangerous situation I would agree but
mass you know movements are always
dangerous but my point is that I think
that if you if you can keep your calm
you can think clearly about what you're
saying also if you've thought about
these ideas before in the cool of the
day so it's not the heat at the moment
said like I've really thought about
these ideas this is not just a sudden
heat of passion like I thought about
this topic or at this point whatever it
is it doesn't have to be a political
point it can be scientific point or
something then when you're pressed you
know you can say you know I'm listening
to you here's what I think okay what do
you think I think you can I think you
can you can I won't say you can win the
panel ideas but you can at least fight
it well yeah what was the
administration's response after this
well I think the administration faced a
difficult challenge in deciding what to
do many people have commented on what
they did or didn't do I'm not sure I
want to go into it it took them quite a
while to come to to release any kind of
public statement in support of us so and
you know many members of the
administration junior members were
actually involved in so in the crowd
that day there were four for
administrators actually who you know
whose others have since identified but
you know I think I don't think
it was Yale at its best and and I don't
and the students were not at their best
and and I was not at my best I did my
best but you know I think I could have
done even better so as someone that then
has lived through it where did this go
wrong on college campuses because for
the past couple years every time I see
one of these stories I think either well
I used to think oh this will this is the
end of it now people will really get it
like I remember you're the one with you
from the other video clip that we didn't
show that people had seen it was like
this is so patently absurd maybe this
will finally be the wake-up call I've
now come to believe that the wake up
call is in coming anytime soon
sadly but what when do you think as well
I think this is a complicated topic I
see you know this is not was not my area
of expertise I am a natural and social
scientist I run a lab with computer
scientists and molecular biologists and
sociologists and evolutionary biologists
and we work around the world we do all
kinds of stuff so I I was I have always
been committed to liberal principles
including to free speech when when I was
at Harvard before I moved to Yale in
2013 my wife and I came to the defense
of minority students who were being
having their write their speech rights
squelched on campus so it's I'm
committed to these ideas but it wasn't
like the most central part of my life
and I'm not an expert like John Hyde or
Greg lucky off luciano far however so I
see conflicting evidence I agree with
you that there are a lot of these
salient cases which which they weren't
before and Jonathan feels that they're
still rising and they have their own
theories Jonathan and Greg about why I
see other evidence that looks at surveys
of college students and finds that they
are no more or less likely to want to
suppress the speech of others than
adults than older adults it's very
tempting to silence people who don't
agree with right I mean everyone wants
to do that no I don't I want to talk to
them and persuade them like you know it
would be it would be very tempting to
like you know shut the anti-vaxxers up
you know prevent them from speaking but
that doesn't win right that that's not a
victory what we need to do is persuade
them why do you believe think this so so
if you compare college students adults
some evidence suggests they're not more
sanctimonious um
evidence suggests there are some polls
if you look at dis invitations they're
clearly rising but they're still small
so so the critics say there's a rising
level of dissing vacations which I
deplore let me just can I go on a
digression yeah yes so I have no let me
very clear because there's a lot of
sloppy thinking about this nobody has a
right to speak on a college campus so
I'm not claiming that anyone has a right
but once a group on campus right invites
you to speak
you cannot yield to the mob for a dis
invitation it totally destroys the
university it's it's the antithesis of
what our university should be like so
you can protest that person but you
cannot have dis invitations that's just
ridiculous
so so there so those have been rising
but so the critics say look this
invitation oven rising but the
defendants a guess but millions of talks
take place and nobody objects so it's a
tiny minority so to answer your question
I don't I don't think we're beyond the
hump but I'm not the expert to tell you
how bad is it does it say something
about the state of liberalism or in a
way that that this was sort of the end
conclusion of liberalism I hate to say
it that it would get sort of usurped by
progressivism or whatever the new
collectivist idea was in other words
liberals are tolerant liberals generally
or live-and-let-live so it was sort of
fertile ground for people with bad ideas
to rush in and kind of take over where
perhaps conservatives are a little
harder to get in at because there it is
yeah yeah but conservatives have their
own political failings right never doubt
yeah they'll move in lockstep so you can
get them to like you know you to to mark
to get to get to organize an inquisition
right so you know it's not like right we
get there it's not comparing either
right and I'm just saying that there's
there there's something a weakness of
nihilism which is very sad for me to say
the openness is exactly what invites
yeah so this is radicalism within yeah
so I mean I think this is I mean I think
you know the open society and its and
its enemies you know I think there is a
sense in which you can use the tools to
destroy the foundation but I also think
and this is one of
the arguments that I made and I actually
believe politically which is that these
very core commitments to freedom of
assembly freedom of expression which the
students were using right now
now we're also engaging in harassment
yeah which is a different topic and you
because I was an actor in those events I
I was was I didn't feel at liberty to
help the students see the difference
between freedom of expression and
harassment right yeah somehow I don't
think they would have been like oh let's
sit down and listen to him as you
explain it explains why you know so you
can so the classic example is the you
know is that you know you can you can
march through the streets of Skokie
Illinois but you can't stop in front of
my house right right because you know
that is a threat the political
expression in a public place is not so
so so the students so there's so I lost
my train of thought or was I going well
basically the idea that the liberalism
and that yeah so so these are core that
sort of non corrupt judiciary sort
impartial separation of powers a freedom
of assembly freedom of speech I regard
these as like foundational principles of
our democracy which are central liberal
principles which the students in some
ways we're using right except to call
for people to be fired for expressing
their ideas on a college campus is using
these principles but to illiberal ends
and this is what you're asking I think
which is what you're saying is can these
tools be used to like degrade the and
and the answer is yes there is a kind of
threat from within but I still wouldn't
abandon the principles and I don't want
to abandon the penis Lizzie there okay
there we go you shift to the book or you
want to keep going no no no please
please I would much rather talk about
this book all right so it's called
blueprint the evolutionary origins of a
good society so let's start with the tag
there so we actually live in a good
society I can't believe it I thought we
live in the worst society and I thought
capitalism is evil and the patriarchy
had so many terrible things and we've
done horrible things but you say this is
good yeah I'm appalled can you please
explain this yes statement yes okay so I
think there has been a long tradition in
the sciences and in the public domain as
well of focusing on the bad side of
human nature
on our propensity for tribalism or
selfishness or violence or hatred but
equally we are natural selection of our
evolution has equipped us and shaped us
for love and friendship and cooperation
and teaching and all these other
wonderful qualities and in fact I would
argue that these good qualities and
their benefits must necessarily have
outweighed the bad qualities and their
costs because if I came near you I'm now
speaking over evolutionary time over
tens or hundreds of thousands of years
if I came near you and you killed me or
filled me with lies or otherwise injured
me I would be better off living
separately so so the so the fact that we
live socially suggests that on balance
the benefits of a connected life must
outweigh the costs so the books the book
that what I'm trying to do is I'm trying
to push back at these claims that we are
either humans are inexorably evil and
these arguments I should make I should
say are supplementary to the body of
ideas that Steven Pinker and others have
been advancing about the sweep of
history so where Steven is interested in
historical forces I'm interested in the
books over there so yeah and Amy's I see
in a bunch of other the other Steven
anyway all my friends yes please put me
over there with those guys yes exactly
you like some of those guys yes and
schirmer's book I can see yeah these are
great okay so uh yeah the moral arc okay
great so I'll make sure you have a copy
Oh keep it anyway so so um so so Steven
is arguing that you know basically since
the the Enlightenment with the
philosophical principles and the
scientific described discoveries of the
Enlightenment the world is been getting
better and he's a unquestionably bright
we are safer less violent healthier live
longer wealthier better off in every
every possible dimension and that is
largely a product of historical forces
but what I'm arguing and technological
forces but what I'm arguing so we don't
just have to look to our history to find
this goodness we can look to our
prehistory and actually over tens of
thousands of years we've been shaped to
be good
we have been shaped to be able to live
together in productive ways in
in in good ways actually in morally good
ways I even argued so so the both works
synergistically these two forces and in
and in fact I would even argue that
these historical and technological
forces are actually just a thin veneer
on top of much more powerful forces so
is there a bizarre evolutionary force
that that inclines us to focus on the
negative
oh no that's a good question I suspect
if I have to I get one per show no no I
would say right because yes if you had
person are things good or bad people
generally tend to bed we watch local
news that is all terrible news yes we're
conditioned sort of so there must be
something that's leading to that yes I
think that I think I know this has been
studied I'm trying to quickly call the
literature to my mind if I had to
speculate on what the conclusions of
that literature would be it would be
that there's more advantage to paying
attention to bad news and good news that
that the fitness advantages survival
advantage the advantage to your
well-being from noting a fire in your
vicinity or a predator or a killer is
more advantageous to you than then the
noted the noting the on average the
presence of water or a food or a kindly
person so I think I think that that's
probably why we're hardwired to be
pessimistic but actually we're not let
me be clear so so we we have both
pessimistic and optimistic inclinations
people and of course there's inter
individual variation people vary in this
these are personality traits but I think
overall we are definitely inclined to
the good so when you describe yourself
as an optimist before if you had to try
to parse that out between what you think
human nature is versus upbringing and
everything else could you give it some
percentages I mean were your parents
optimists so that then push to you or I
think it's important not to conflate
personality traits which I am optimist I
think good person by personality with
sort of how to put this exactly the kind
of characteristics of our species so I
think we for example we're a cooperative
species we we cooperate with straight
which is very unusual other animals will
cooperate with kin but we also cooperate
with non kin it's rare in the animal
kingdom so I don't know how you would
describe that I wouldn't call that
optimism exactly I would call that
something good popper tippity that's a
characteristic of our species and then
above and beyond that we also have
personalities with some of us are
optimistic some of us or not but all of
us
for example love our mates so here's an
interesting idea why why do we do that
did other animals have sex with each
other we're not the only animals that do
this but we also love each other we form
sentimental attachments to the people
we're having sex with we are also tend
to be monogamous now we can be by
monogamous I don't mean social monogamy
or even heterosexual monogamy I mean we
form a long-term attachment to the
person we're having sex with whether
it's polygynous polyandrous straight or
gay doesn't matter we love the person
we're with why why do we have all this
capacity well I talked a little bit
about that yeah why do that and it's
Universal everywhere in the world you go
no matter what the marital system people
love their partners it's at least unless
we get too proud of ourselves Birds 90%
of bird species are also monogamous but
anyway so the point is is that there are
all these qualities we have or we
befriend each other why do we do that we
we don't just reproduce with each other
we form long-term non reproductive
unions with other members of our species
namely we have friends this is very rare
in the animal kingdom we do it certain
primates do it whales orcas and dolphins
do it and elephants do it why well
there's a reason we do it and it's a
wonderful quality of our species so do
you think societies should be organized
to help these institutions I mean this
is where I could throw out Jordan
Peterson's enforced monogamy yes and you
know people had a field day with that
and all he really was saying was that
societies should kind of look at
marriage as an innocent thing because
it's a foundational thing that will help
you build a family that helped you build
a full life do you agree that that's
part of what would lead to a good
society or what should be instilled well
I say well I talked about that in the
book what I talked about is that we
should be very wary of efforts to
engineer society and opposition to our
evolved proclivities
so society's a try for example to
prevent loving attachments I talked
about communes for example communes have
a problem because in a commune they want
you to feel loyalty to the group to the
commune
so therefore feeling a love for your
partner is a threat so many communes
have gone to opposite extremes both of
which are attempting to solve the same
problem so on the one hand you have the
shakers who say no sex no loving
attachment on the other hand you have
communes that say polyamory everyone
loves everybody or can have sex with
everyone
both of those are attempting to sever an
individualistic connection between two
people which therefore you and the same
thing happens in eastern Germany where
they try to sever connections with
friends right you don't you my friends
could be spying on your ratting me out
to the Stasi the way it's worth sitting
there for a second it's a fascinating
idea it's the same force at work whether
you have say two people don't have any
religious he's actually the same yet
worse as have relations yes with
everybody I mean that's that's not
something that the average person is
thinking about but if you're just having
relations and everybody yes you're
actually nothing special nobody that's
right
so they're both both of those extreme
strategies are tackling the same problem
which is the threat to the collectivity
of individual relationships whether it's
with your partner your sexual partner or
those about saying with your friends or
others so collectivist societies will
often everywhere everyone call you
comrade so everyone is your friend same
as having polyamory right it's like the
polyamorous equivalent to everyone
dresses the same we all call each other
friend no individual identity it's a
kind of it's a kind of science fiction
dystopia actually so the argument I make
is is that we should be very wary of
efforts to engineer society in
opposition to our interests they're
bound to fail is my argument now there
are brief moments of time and certain
cultures where you can apply a
tremendous cultural force and suppress
some of these innate tendencies so for
example that I talked about the NA so if
you look at societies around the world
that the the the expression of love for
your partner's seen universally accepted
one exception which is the not people in
the Himalayas who have organized society
around brief sexual encounters you're
not supposed to love your partner and so
this is a matrilineal society the women
stay at home
the men will go out at night basically
cruising for dates so they'll be like
and it's not uncommon for every woman to
have had sex with every man in the
village and the men will be knocking on
the door take meat and I take me and
she'll pick this guy tonight and they'll
have a brief fling maybe he can come
back and at any moment either of them
can break off the relationship but even
in it and so there's a whole complex
cultural edifice Marco Polo describes
this when he gets to China the the the
Chinese government thought it was
sapping productivity that everyone was
having sex all the time they were they
were saying and needs to stop this they
tried to stamp it out but it still has
existed this this culture this this
cultural set of rules but even in this
society there are people who want the
forbidden fruit of having a committed
relationship and who flee for because
they want to be with each other
forsaking all others so even this
society cannot fully suppress this
desire for love and I look also at
friendship and show that there are some
societies very few which seem to have no
experience of this notion of friendship
but those societies are extremely rare
and also have certain idiosyncrasies so
with the simple way of saying that be
that there's basically an evolutionary
force that no matter how far you go to
one extreme it has to sort of push you
yes or that it's extremely difficult to
entirely suppress you can through force
of arms you know you can slaughter
populations you can you can you know you
can you can have very elaborate sort of
autocratic governments you you can have
procedures or other highly evolved
stylized cultures that have gotten to
this for example there's a play as
universal in children and there's one
society the baning people who really
think play is awful and really try to
suppress the innate tendency of children
to play so there's very little play
among children in that society but it's
these societies are rare and they
require very large cultural forces to
suppress these innate tendencies you
know I was thinking as we've been
talking about this that there's
something also sort of related to our
political situation right now about this
that it seems like we're sort of going
off the deep end I would say the argue
more on the left at the moment but I
guess if I'm an optimist here and I
describe myself as a world
okay that you're saying at some point
and and whether Jonathan eight says it's
two years down the road or whatever it
is but at some point we'll eventually
have to rebound right yes because sure
because what is it if it doesn't rebound
then then that's just no I don't think
George Peterson would say is just chaos
right yeah I think I think but I I mean
I can't I I think we're in for another I
think it'll be about five or ten years
our society is gonna go through a long
period of of acrimony now I have to say
I'm not you know sir I don't have a wig
issue of history like Oh in the olden
days you know everything was great I
mean let's not forget we had we had
colonialism we had slavery we had we had
anti-immigrant sentiment forever in our
gonna even though vote I mean yes women
couldn't vote exactly but deemed to have
gay rights you know so so there's always
been this this incredible disconnect
between our wonderful principles in our
society all men are created equal
you know the Bill of Rights can bring
tears to your eyes if you read it as but
and the fact that we didn't out but we
are I think getting better this is the
progressive in me you know the society
we're getting better and better we are
expanding the franchise to more and more
people we are opening up our democracy
we are we are extending rights we are
extending liberties now of course the
libertarian will say the government
doesn't grant Liberty we are protecting
liberties or you know we are trying to
stay out of it exactly and I agree with
that actually I don't think the
liberties are the government's to grant
but anyway so but I think our society
isn't getting better in these regards I
don't think you can you could say
otherwise so I think that we we will get
there it's just gonna take some time so
how do you navigate through a messy time
like this if you're someone that's just
kind of awake to these ideas and you
want to be able to express your
individuality but there is a mob or an
amorphous machine that is silencing
things or as you just said before they
you don't want a society that's gonna
push down things that were sort of
always accepted for a long time I'm
slightly paraphrasing but so right now
it's like if you call a man a man
they'll tell you you're trans for these
these basic things that seem now
we hear about them constantly as if as
if this is just the most important thing
happening no I think they're other this
is the other thing I think that I think
there's certain segments of Twitter and
certain segments of our society that
have made these particular topics and
others very central and everyone you
know the people who want to or concern
about climate change for people who can
I am there people are concerned about
the private Prentis prison industry as I
am these are two hot topics at Harvard
right now so there was a heckler
situation where the president of Harvard
was was not allowed to speak about he
was at an educational conference and
these groups that were opposed to
private ownership of prisons which I am
and concern about climate change which I
also AM they shut the president now
which is ridiculous you know why did
they because they thought he wasn't
taking paying enough attention to their
concern so you you have this kind of
ruled by minorities right where a
minority can hijack the conversation
about whatever particular topic they
have so everyone's entitled to have
their topics of interest but that
doesn't mean you have to go along with
it right you can have your own ideas
about the topic or you can switch
conversation like I'm not interested in
talking about trans rights today today
I'd like to talk about how motor vehicle
accidents are the one of the leading
killers or the opioid crisis is another
important dilemma or the guns you know
we we we have we have more people are
killed by guns in our society per capita
than any society in the world almost
it's craziness so so all of these are
different people of different anyway the
point I'm making is that you know if you
wish to engage in a conversation with
someone about a topic they feel strongly
about I think it's incumbent on you to
listen to their arguments think and then
respond so do you think there's an
evolutionary reason that people either
basically become sort of government
people or freedom people so the way you
were laying out that argument a second
ago it's like you were telling me your
progressive surprise read which I have
to do at the time but then you basically
said yeah but all these things can be
accomplished by libertarianism if you
don't believe that it's the government
job to give these things so that
basically it sort of shows why the the
progressives are the ones screaming on
campus all the time and in larger
society because they think the system
can be perfected to get it however they
want where are the libertarians I think
just say I'm very wary of
right yeah I don't think the system can
be perfect so let's just keep it out of
our lives I mean I think you know which
which idea I'm sympathetic to but do you
think there's a reason that well I think
or is that yes I okay so there are there
are a set of ideas about where do where
do so so the content of political
beliefs like whether for example you
believe in whatever it is pick it I know
any the the the the belief you have
about a particular topic is of course
not evolutionarily shaped but there is a
kind of evolutionary shaping to whether
or not you are more conservative or
liberal right so that's that's what I'm
trying to yeah so some people are more
rule-abiding and there's an there's a
good for example children that learn
children that listen to their parents
might be more likely to survive so
listening to your parents is actually a
good survival strategy on the other hand
too much obedience is also bad you can
be led like a lemming off a cliff so
occasionally you need to not listen to
what everyone else is doing so both are
advantageous and we're we're equipped
with both abilities and there's
variation across people and it's a
complicated topic so nobody thinks
there's like a genetic background to
being a Democrat or a Republican but
right there is evidence that there is a
kind of genetic predisposition to
certain political polls but what I would
say though is that we live in a plural
democracy so you're gonna have to
compromise you know if you're
libertarian who thinks XY and Z and
you're gonna be in a society with other
people who think different things we
have decided to come together as a
people and vote to resolve our disputes
and to by the way not just to vote but
to educate ourselves and to teach each
other stuff right to communicate right
the founders recognized that in order
for us to get to the wisest decision we
attempt free and open conversation well
I think that's why which I said what I
do here of course you do but that's why
so many people are so concerned about
this at the college layer you know I'll
hear some of our critics will say oh
they're just obsessed with what's
happening on colleges and they're
handing over all this power to the to
the mob on colleges but then but then
everyday we see it then leaked out and
also these people will be the leaders of
tomorrow that's why I don't think it's I
don't think it's overestimating it even
if it is a small minority which we
agree the amount of power they can
extend they definitely used to be way
disproportionate to the numbers for sure
I would agree with that I would agree
that the vast majority of students on
any college campus just want to get a
good education and and many of them have
other political concerns other than some
of the ones that are getting a lot of
attention so you know even for example
even with the you know so you know
people are concerned about the opioid
crisis they're concerned about gun
violence or concerned about police
brutality they're concerned about the
climate change they're concerned about
all of these issues which I think
weren't concerned we can perfect our
society we can be better than we are and
I generally we can perfect it I do
better than we are you think we can
perfect it no I don't think we can have
a perfect society but I think we can
make it better than it is
so by perfect I mean improve okay so I
think we can make our society better and
better I don't think we're done yet I
think there's still deficits or for
example our spending is crazy I mean I
think we do better fiscal fiscally you
know I think we we have we have a car
serial state we have I think I think
this numbers right that are on a per
capita basis we have as many people in
prisons as Stalinist Russia I mean it's
insane you know we we have millions of
Americans are in prison and it's way out
of proportion to other countries you
know there are lots of things about our
society we have very high we have
century-long heights of income
inequality in our society there's a big
debate about whether that is an
unavoidable side-effect of growth you
know everyone is better off so what do
we care if the income is unequally
distributed but I think I tend to be
agree with the critics that are
concerned that this level of inequality
is not sustainable to have a common
wheel to like have a sense that everyone
is a part of the society
we've had no income growth in the middle
like the median American has seen in a
generation has seen no growth in wages
right so the bottom actually has raised
and we watched the top go bananas but
the middle base no the bottom hasn't
even gone out that much either well let
me put this way they have absolutely not
been living standards right right so
like a poor America today is vastly
better off than a poor American a
generation ago but in terms of wage
growth there's been very little growth
my understanding of statistics and most
of the accumulation and wealth in the
last generation has gone to the top top
one percent on point one percent anyway
there's a debate about why that happened
a technological advance do we have the
same thing during the industrial
these are important deep ideas which as
a society we should be debating and be
discussing what's the best for our
society anyway
third these are all much more important
topics in my view and have much more
bearing on the well-being of our society
than a lot of the other crap that gets
so much attention so what's the
evolutionary reason for that I mean your
previous book well that was about social
media right nobody so there's got to be
some link there I mean and I get back to
what I was saying about depressing local
news I don't know I mean I'm trying to
talk about things that I think are
important you know I I'm doing my part
as best I can
who's done a society in a more
quote-unquote good way so I so the book
so I don't I don't I'm not it's not a
work of history so I'm not I'm not I
don't primarily talk about like the last
200 or even 2,000 years of human
evolution or experience I'm much more
interested in the long arc of our
history and if you look at forager
societies around the world as I do and
you and you look at their qualities you
will see that again and again these
societies have these desirable
properties they there's very ancient of
course and how cooperative they are and
there's variation and marital systems
and there's variation and in sustenance
systems there's a lot of variation but
also there's a lot of commonality and
and those common features I argue are
Universal see here's the other argument
so the argument is that there are these
universal qualities that are shared
across all societies they are shaped by
our evolution they're not just a product
of historical forces can you just list
out a couple of them so so loves from
what soul of friendship cooperation
where cooperative species you'll be kind
to a stranger on the first you know
teaching the fact that we teach each
other stuff which actually is the
ultimate source of all our wealth and
well-being the fact that we can
accumulate knowledge and distribute it
across time and place so I can tell
people far away something and when I'm
born I benefit from all the other
knowledge that has been produced for the
minute did hundreds of thousands of
years before me it's a spawning and I
would again argue this is
why what's happening oncology yes such a
concern I would argue I would agree with
that there's a connection there like our
capacity to teach and to create
environments in which we foster teaching
and learning are crucial anyway also
mild hierarchy we are species that we
cannot survive with no hierarchy mm-hmm
we need some leaders and I discussed
that but we also don't like too much
hierarchy so when you get to autocratic
of power the low guys down below band
together and basically kill so Richard
Wrangham has been making this argument
that we self domesticated as a species
that over millennia bands of weaker
members would say you know that guy is
too powerful and he's getting all the
dates and this we're gonna kill him
and basically they did so we got more
peaceful as time went by as one of the
ideas mild hierarchy in-group bias so
some tribalism is unavoidable in human
beings this capacity for identity that
we discussed at the beginning these are
all qualities so identity love
friendship social networks mild
hierarchy in-group bias teaching and
social learning these are seen
everywhere and they lie and I believe at
the core of a good society and and
institutions try to suppress those at
their own peril yeah how can you sort of
have a healthy dose of in-group
preference without starting to fall into
the trap of identity politics so for
example your Greek guys yes I've been in
a Greek fat kid I love Greek is my best
child friend is blowing up in the Greek
we're still great friends I love Greek
culture and the way we'd open a Greek
and the interest in in intellectualism
and I love feta cheese and all those
things spanakopita yes yes great so what
and you could open a Greek restaurant as
far as I'm concerned I wouldn't object
poor that poor girl it's insane
yeah no Chinese without being Chinese
and this is coming not just that there
was that there's the person in in in
Oregon that had a Mexican yes so many
examples it is unbelievable so how can
you say love okay I just told you all
the reasons that later but let's pretend
yes but I'd say it's roughly the same
feel about your own culture how can you
embrace all of those things without
falling into the trap of identity
politics because I think that yeah so I
think where a lot of people are at these
days okay so I have a couple of ideas in
response to the first thing I
would say is is that that this is one of
the both the most it's still not totally
clear how we evolved to have this
capacity it's felt that this in-group
bias this this tribalism that we have
was crucial to our ability to cooperate
that the ability to draw a distinction
between us and them that the challenge
the problem that that this ability that
we evolved so so there's whether we
cooperate with each other and whether we
are xenophobic or tribalistic or draw
distinctions between us and them and
this property this tribalism property is
a property that reduces the scale of
interactions so instead of you having to
cooperate with everybody you only
cooperate with your guys and this is
innate in human beings and it is felt
that this ability to draw a distinction
between us and then was crucial in the
emergence of the very ability to
cooperate with in other people okay so
they're tied they're connected to each
other what's depressing is is it
necessary to hate the other group why
can't you just love your own group right
so why could you be indifferent to the
other group or even admire and say
that's them they're not us we like them
or we were different today right why do
we have to kill them right like why you
know where does the killing part come
from and this is complicated we don't
exactly know like where the hostility
comes in whether but we tend to see this
hostility so for example their famous
experiments that have been done with
little toddlers you can randomly assign
toddlers to different t-shirts you can
test that the toddlers understand that
this was random that there was no merit
to whether they got the yellow t-shirt
or the green t-shirt and yet as soon as
you give them the t-shirts the yellow
t-shirt kids say those green t-shirt
children they shouldn't have toys
they're bad children they don't deserve
you know anything
it's insane look it like you consumed
it's called the minimal group
experiments so with the most trivial of
interventions you can illicit in us this
this this dislike of the other however
this is not the only tool that evolution
has given us to live together this this
ability to draw the boundary between us
and them there are a couple of other
tools and before I tell you what those
two other tools are let me just say one
other thing so if you think of our
society as here's our whole society and
here's our groups and the
and here individuals at the bottom if
you're struggling with the problem of
tribalism they're basically two ways you
can go you can go up a level and broaden
the boundary and you can say for example
we are all Americans hmm right you can
say because we all have the capacity to
draw the boundary we are evolved to have
that capacity now you just say actually
these little group boundaries that we
were paying attention to they're not
they're not relevant and so basically
take all the ethnic divisions or all the
religious or immigrants or whatever it
is they we're all American we're all
Americans that's other group at a higher
level exactly so you move up a level and
you if face tribalism by appeal to
larger groups this has been part of our
history since the beginning to talk
Ville talks about this we're a nature of
joiners you know and anyone can be an
American that itself as part of the
American project it's astonishing the
belief which I share that anyone can be
an American is a statement that the
group's don't matter anyone can be an
American you just have to buy our
liberal principles and there's also an
interesting parable to subtract here
because at some level it's like he's
talking about America all the time so
that is the higher group for all yes and
yet I suspect your feelings on what do
you do yes ratio there's some other
things probably not so no but I would be
Lenny one could be an American if you
come to our country and you work and are
productive and and obey our laws and our
Constitution you're an American as far
as I'm concerned didn't matter whether
you came from Mexico or you know one of
the four Mexican countries is he's you
know anyway okay so a whole other show
okay so so okay so so but another
solution okay if to the group is of the
tribalism is to go down a level remember
we talked earlier about individuals so
now you can say instead of looking at
people as which groups are they a member
of you look at them as individual people
and this too has been a part of our
history so Martin Luther King's famous
sentiment I you know I'd look forward to
a society in which people are judged by
the content of their character rather
than the color of their skin is it
appeal to our individuality
I think groups don't matter individuals
matter so so if we're struggling with
tribalism we go up or we can go down
both help however lateral to that point
there's another set of ideas which is
try
ilysm is not even the only tool we have
in order to reduce the sense of scale
and to cooperate so natural selection
has also equipped us with friendship
friendship the real one of the reasons
it is felt we evolve the capacity for
friendship is again to reduce the sense
of scale so instead of now I'm being in
a big group everyone has to cooperate
with everyone each of us has a subset of
people who are our friends that we
cooperate with so it's similar tribalism
but different because now instead of
defining it by a group membership is
defined by each person has their
particular friends so this is another
tool that we innately have that we can
use to sustain our cooperative instincts
and push aside the tribalism so how much
do you think on a day-to-day they and a
day-to-day basis are we normally I get
the water for people you have to be so
wrapped up there that's what I forgot on
a day-to-day basis how much movement do
we as individuals have to sort of either
go around let's say go around our
evolutionary behavior well I don't think
okay so I think I do believe in free
will I mean I think you have some
capacity to self mastery and make your
own decisions in life and your own you
know but you're also born with certain
innate qualities and you're also born a
human being which is you're part of a
particular species that has a particular
set of characteristics so I I think that
as individuals you know we we have some
control over how we act I don't think
our individual actions will individually
change the whole society but I think if
each of us is attempting to do the right
thing I think ultimately that makes
things better look there's a lot of
famous ideas so a Viktor Frankl who was
in the concentration camps his wife was
killed he survives the Nazi
concentration camps and he goes and he
writes a famous book called man's search
for meaning after he's liberated it
writes it ten days after his liberation
and he talks about how he came to the
recognition that even in this camp in
the most vile possible circumstances
where his life was threatened every day
where people were dying all the time he
was
starving to death he had no shoes it was
in the winter I mean it was a slave even
there he recognized that he was the
master of his own internal state you
know that how he saw the world was
something that was in his own control so
he was able to find a sense of self
discipline and mastery even in an
environment in which the structures
around him were engineered to crush him
to kill him so so I think that there and
there many examples of this I mean
another one of my favorite examples is
Buddhist monks that were studied at MIT
years ago I think I'm gonna get the
facts of this were correct so so so they
were very interested in how meditation
changes the structure of your brain and
how are these monks so able to be so
peaceful
in these very stressful circumstances
and they scan them they put them in the
MRI scanner and they looked at different
parts of their brain and which parts
were enhanced or diminished compared to
other more ordinary mortals and and then
and and they saw that different parts of
the brain and Buddhist monks were
different than the rest of us but what
interested me was not even the
neuroanatomical discoveries that were in
that paper but it was the interviews
with the monks and so what the monks
would say was that for example let's say
you and I are in traffic and someone
cuts us off a normal response certainly
one that I often have is man who is that
jerk you know I'm gonna be really pissed
off and your blood pressure would rise
to maybe you'd race that guy and you
know you would you would think you loved
them that would be your natural go-to
thing that's a thoughtless maybe their
idiotic or their inattentive or you
would have all these bad thoughts about
this person who you know in a road rage
kind of way
the monks don't do that but the monks do
is is they train themselves to rina rate
so when that happens to them they say
maybe that's a man who's taking his wife
to the hospital because she's delivering
the baby the babies being born in the
car in front of me isn't that amazing
there's a new life I should help that
man to get to the ha I mean and they're
doing it not for the sake of that person
but for their own well-being you see so
so I think it's possible to to to to or
even though it's difficult it is very
difficult to exercise some internal
self-control I think you're mostly
saying that
there are no monks on Twitter yes very
few the Dalai Lama I think's on Twitter
I think I found I think I have to check
yeah he's on Facebook I'm pretty sure
what else do you think sort of the
average person that's watching this can
do to help order a good society because
I think people you know everything's
become so political yes that I think
people think that's the only solution to
sort of help make a better I think
granting charity to your enemies I think
is important I think listening to them
cultivating listening you know that's
pretty big of you to say after
everything that you well I was listening
in the clip you shot I was listening I
thought that was the ridiculous
the young woman who said I'm not
listening to her I was really listening
yeah I mean I was listening then and
before and after I don't agree with what
she was saying but I heard what she said
so I could summarize what she was saying
but even but what do you do in that case
then it just sort of yeah we'd have to
bring it back to them if against its but
in generals because I think a lot of
people are going through this you're
being berated by somebody they're saying
all the worst things about you yes
feuding your motives yes you're
attacking you as a person all of those
things now you could listen you can
absorb you can ignore you can ignore or
which is also good Ruth Bader Ginsburg
says the survival in life is ignoring a
lot of the stupidities which I also
think is good I think that's the answer
and what was it ignore and also who was
that famous actress that found this guy
in Texas that had said have horrible
things to her and then or him my camera
but was an actor and actress and he was
an actress and made it her business to
find out about this guy's life and he
had lost his health insurance and he and
then she intervened and raised money for
his health care and and and he felt seen
and heard wow I can't it's an incredible
story and and I think that a lot of
times people and I think anonymity is a
real it can contribute to bad behavior
online so I think sort of as jordan
peterson says you know man up as it were
woman up and have the strength of your
convictions this is what i think this is
what I'm gonna say but is there a
problem I mean Jordan I've done this
many times where then depending on how
that hierarchical structure is operated
if you are saying something that's
unpolitical II yes correct well I mean
you have to have the strength rule or
revise your opinions or stick to them or
make good arguments but we're listening
but you
or don't engage let's say you're a trump
supporter you just want to lose your job
because you think if you say that I'm
against people losing their jobs for
their opinion yeah so so you know so I
think that I think there's a thing where
I think a little bit of bravery a little
bit of civil discourse a little bit of
commitment to granting charity to our
opponents a little bit of like for
example when I would have an argument
with people who are opposed to
vaccination I think there is no merit to
their ideas I understand their fears
I understand that there have been either
some actual cases of vaccine induced
neurological conditions one in a hundred
thousand one in five hundred thousand
cases which is awful and I understand
that there are a lot of coincidences
where people think that there's a
relationship but no it's just that you
have you know you have a lot of vaccines
are being administered there are a lot
of illnesses occurring there's gonna be
an overlap in those two sets but and I
also know the date on how that's very
bitter how vaccination is like a twenty
twentieth and twenty it's actually more
like even a 19th century triumph I mean
you know we've we've mastered these
diseases we humans it's astonishing what
we've done through our capacity to teach
and learn and engage in science and so
forth but I would engage that person I
would try to I would talk to them I
would say you know let me talk to you
about your beliefs and because I think
that that's the only way to get them to
revise their beliefs
I think telling them they're fools
doesn't doesn't help yeah true liberal I
am a liberal yes I am I am I am a
liberal yeah but do you think one side
is a little it's a little bit easier to
do that right now and does that flip
over time so for example right now I
find it much easier you know to go to
concert I get invited by an observant of
clips libertarians is no problem but if
a conservatives that I have
disagreements on on abortion yes gain in
origin legalizing marijuana and the
desert wealthy and we could do the list
hold on so I'm for legalization
marijuana yes what is your position on
death penalty
um I guess me to gay marriage yes yeah
legalizing weed yes so I could put yes
so I hate to tell you I'm guessing that
you only would get invited by
conservative groups to basically to
college well I don't know I don't know I
don't get that many I mean usually my
invitations are scientific like I'm a
scientist like I give talks about my
science so I I have not historically
been very politically but right so but
what I'm getting at really
at the moment it seems very obvious to
me like I don't know that I could be
clearer on anything that is on the
center-right there's there is a an
ability and actually a desire to discuss
ideas out gree to disagree and that just
isn't happening
right well I would right now and I would
suspect or argue and I'm sure you give
me examples where that yes I mean during
McCarthyism for example I think you know
it's very difficult to be the Communists
for sure and even you know left-wing
fifties so they weren't inviting
communist yes that's right that's right
and so I think I honestly don't know the
answer to that question I think there
are subgroups on campus which are still
committed to debate they get the
political union's these guys love to
argue these young people I think there
are other vocal minorities on campus
that don't want to hear opinions that
they don't agree with and they think
that even the hearing of it there's this
there's this very sloppy conflation of
speech with violence which i think is
ridiculous which seems to really be
ramping up yes I would agree with that
and you also see it burn instance in
Pakistan they will they will kill
apostates well that's answering speech
with violence if you actually think that
someone believing in a different God and
expressing that belief is violence then
then that country justifies killing that
person or in Brunei recently they have
the same kind of situation I think this
this is I I strongly reject that belief
there's there's a we have different
words and there's a totally different
meaning between speech and violence so
so I don't know how we got onto that
topic but oh so so I think that I think
there are my groups of people on campus
who do conflate speech and violence I
think that's a problem but there are
also many groups that are very very
vigorous political debates I think one
thing that is different so I'm in my 50s
when I was in college in my in the 80s
we would stay up late and argue about
politics with our friends with our
friends notice I said yeah yeah my
friend yeah I would argue with my
friends about politics and and they were
my friends I don't think that happens
very much anymore it does in the
political unions in the debate societies
but in the broader college I think if
you have a different opinion about
abortion for example you really can't
express that but the weird thing is that
it is happening with conservatives
well I can't say because they do believe
I mean I go to these things and I have
these debates yes kids overall and
they're better debater says they have
more experience yes arguing with people
they disagree with yeah yes they get a
better education in some ways because
they have to constantly defend their
opinions it's a weird thing being little
happy to say that yes yes yes I think
well I mean if you this is the thing why
in the martial arts for example why do
we bow to our opponent you learn more
from the people you disagree with and
from the people you agree with right and
jeaious Mills famous saying you know he
who knows only his side of the case
knows little of it
so you know I think I think that's where
your ideas get better when they are
tested when you argue with someone you
disagree with and and and I think and I
think cultivating those kinds of
conversations disciplining yourself to
be able to have arguments with people
you disagree with improves your ideas
and actually you should be grateful to
that person there's more interesting
person in some ways now you don't have
to be best friends with that person
necessarily although you can be but I
think it makes you smarter that my
friend is a nice closing statement and
you've lived through it I mean that's
the knowing you you lived through the
forces that so many of us see now is as
such dangerous forces in society and now
that you lived through it you flourished
and you've got another book out and all
of those things well I would say I mean
yeah well I would close was saying you
know I really believe that that the arc
of our evolution is long but it bends
towards goodness sounds good to me
you guys could follow Nick on Twitter at
na Christakis and we'll have a link to
his book right down below
you
[Music]